the world's largest retailer has stopped
selling guns and bullets to anyone under
21 Walmart says in light of recent
events we've taken an opportunity to
review our policy on firearm sales that
statement came just hours after Dick's
Sporting Goods announced it will pull
all remaining assault-style rifles from
its shelves and raise its age limit for
gun sales Kris Van Cleave is outside a
Walmart in Alexandria Virginia with the
about-face Kris good morning good
morning Walmart stopped selling assault
style rifles in - in 2015 now dicks
stopped selling those rifles in most of
its stores back in 2012 in a sense now
pulled them out of its field and stream
stores as well that only leaves Cabela's
and Bass Pro Shops which are owned by
the same company as the last major
national retailer still selling these
assault style rifles Walmart's decision
to raise its age restriction on firearms
purchases - 21 comes two weeks after the
parklands shootings we have heard you
the CEO of Dick's Sporting Goods said in
response to the students outcry and
issued a call to action to ban assault
style firearms raise the minimum age to
purchase firearms to 21 and ban
high-capacity magazines and bump stocks
their business decision is notable their
call to action is heroic
David Shipman is a former ATF special
agent who now works with the Giffords
Law Center to Prevent Gun Violence where
do you think the tipping point is I have
a sense that the tipping point happened
the minute these kids started speaking
out and are just absolutely frustrated
that their parents adults and their
country hasn't taken care of them
Walmart and dicks join a growing list of
companies changing their stance on guns
or cutting ties with the National Rifle
Association
but it's still not hard to get assault
weapons people get a lot of pleasure out
of shooting these things you know and
they have a they have a excellent
self-defense value chip Jarrell works
for a gun shop in Warrenton Virginia and
says he's seen an increase in demand for
assault style rifles whenever they feel
like the opportunity to buy those might
go away it's like well I better get in
and I better get in and do it now before
it's gone another gun store manager told
us his store has seen a three-fold
increase in sales of weapons in the last
couple of weeks Walmart says in light of
recent events it's also going to remove
any items from its websites that
resemble assault style rifles that
includes airsoft guns and toys Gayle all
right thank you Chris